all right so i'll have you just say
inspire your name
uh barbara buckley
b-a-r-b-a-r-a-b-u-c-k-l-e-y
perfect and a title i can give you um
for this
purpose um the um leading the rapid
reform
response strike force on the
unemployment benefit issue
perfect all right so i guess uh
online there's a bunch of facebook
groups i've been i actually interviewed
a gentleman today he
got paid this week for a who will claim
it uh what's going on with that
are you noticing more people getting
paid
yeah so um since the strike force uh
started about a month ago
and our new acting director was
appointed
um we have uh processed about 14
000 claims in the backlog so i think
you're slowly beginning to see people
um you know share the good news that
they've been paid
but and we're thrilled at that but we
have a lot more progress
to accomplish we are continuing to
engage in plans to reduce the backlog
including a team of 30 adjudicators
reporting to work at seven a.m
tomorrow morning to try to see if they
can get
you know another one or two thousand
people paid
so we're not arresting on this progress
we're we're
pushing through to get 100 percent of
the backlog
reduced let's talk about the staffing
levels i know
our previous interview you talked about
uh adding uh people from another
department uh
bringing in retired employees where are
we with that
yeah so uh 200 welfare eligibility
work workers finished two weeks of
training
and soon we're going to deploy them on
people
stuck between two systems
so some people are eligible under pua
some people are eligible under regular
ui
so many people have applied for poet and
have been waiting but they're really
eligible
in ui and it's federal law we have no
discretion over it
so what we're going to do with these
workers is have them reach out to people
and say your claim was filed in the
wrong system can we take a claim from
you
over the phone to get you paid in the
right system
so rather than having them wait and get
frustrated and call into the call center
actually proactively try to resolve
their case
has there been a change with the phone
system i don't know or maybe the
protocol with the
people who are answering the phone cause
the guy i interviewed he said
this hasn't happened before but he got
through one online and the person
basically
looked at a stop and said okay this is
correct you're good and
that same week he had he had money has
there been any difference with that
um the call volume to the call center
has been reduced because more people are
getting paid
so the more people that get paid the
less people that call the more likely
you are to get through
and not be frustrated so that's improved
but we also announced today that we're
bringing the call center completely
back under dieter so that it is managed
you know by the state
and not by an outside contractor and we
think that's going to
keep people from being bounced back and
forth
and having to wait for someone to review
a claim
so that's going to be another big big
improvement in the system
do you think that theater has the staff
for that or will there be another wave
of staff coming on
so it's it's going to be staggered um so
uh what uh the deputy director is doing
right now
um is creating the right staffing level
so some
some will be existing employees but
we'll manage it
uh some might be contract staff so you
know because we we only have a short
period of time to get it up and running
and won't be able to just
do the usual hiring process uh for
uh she just uh joined at me at her
it's going there we go oh there you go
hey there
oh we're gonna we're getting me set up i
can't do this
on my own i was gonna say that's a far
shot but we got it
how are you i'm good thank you sorry
about that
i answer some questions and then
whatever you have left
you know you can ask whoever you want
great
and i'll just alyssa alisa i know how
your name is but in case someone else
goes through this interview can i just
have you say
real quick sure it's alisa caferetta and
i'm the acting director of dieter
uh just spell your last name for me it's
kafrata is c-a-f-f
as in frank e-r-a-t-a
okay so we just got finished um talking
about the call center
uh transferring back to dieter and the
employing
employees that will be operating that uh
is there gonna be more employees coming
in
to help with that or how's that going to
work
so we're actually uh working on our
staffing plan
and sort of maximizing all of the
uh resources that we've got so we
um i think we've discussed before we
have 200
folks coming in from welfare who are in
their second week of training
we're going to be um having some of
those in the call center but a large
number of them were going to have
making calls out to the folks who were
told after they applied in pua that they
needed to go back to
regular ui and go through that
eligibility first
so they'll actually be reaching out to
them we will have some of our staff
people who are trained as adjudicators
and can resolve
cases at a higher level and we probably
will have
some vendors staff that will also
fill in as we're making this transition
so we can make it as smooth as possible
but we always knew we were going to have
to bring pua back into
dieter because that program expires so
i just made sense with how complicated
people's cases are to bring it back
sooner
and get started on that so do you think
it'll help the system
absolutely i think so i think we we just
didn't expect to have the number of
people in uh with eligibility in both
systems or
applications in both systems uh olorica
is our pua call center only that's
what they were trained for so uh we just
we we knew we would ultimately get here
we just didn't realize how quickly we
would get here
uh and this is going to allow us to
manage
uh sort of issues as they develop uh
provide the training uh make sure that
folks can
answer the questions that are coming in
and be more responsive so we're really
excited about
uh working with them to make this
transition
yeah we had uh barbara and i were
talking earlier about um
it seems like more poor claimants were
getting getting processed i
we follow i follow the facebook pages
and i've just been singing more than i
have before of people getting getting
paid
do you think moving forward from here
we're just going to see that continue or
what do you expect with that
yeah we've we've been working through
in both systems trying to process as
many folks as we can
so we've uh we've really steadily been
working through
uh pua we do i don't know if barbara
talked about we've got
uh about 30 folks coming in this
saturday
just to focus on pua claims that are
awaiting some kind of
decision resolution someone taking the
having the time to look at the documents
so we're really focusing on who's
who's been waiting to get a resolution
and sort of tackling each one of those
groups as we can
and getting them resolved and when
they're eligible getting them paid so
yes i think you're going to continue to
see that
perfect and then she answered the
questions about staffing that i had
already um
so i have a couple other questions uh if
someone had lost their job due to covet
and they were also given a severance are
they still allowed to collect
unemployment how does that work i've
been
coming across
yeah so so they their their claim might
be adjusted
right so they wouldn't get payment for
the time that they received
it's called deductible income under the
federal law
so there might be a period of time when
they may not be eligible
but after that expires they will be
eligible and the staff
they do sort that out um in the in the
processing of the case
does that make it a little more
complicated i'm guessing for them to
figure that out
yeah i think one thing that uh alisa and
i have discovered in the last 30 days
you know everybody thinks their case is
easy but the federal
laws are very complicated they require
you to consider
a number of steps and so you have to go
through those
and that's what takes more time than we
would like to see
um does the same thing count to
paid time off i mean does if you're paid
that out
does that have to be deducted as well
same thing
yes same thing okay interesting um
what about if your account's frozen you
have to pay money back
um that dates back for months but i mean
let's say for example someone was
getting a severance i mean how does that
work
with with that well um the federal
government
gives again they control these two
programs
so they issue overpayment guidance
and they tell you how you can handle
things
so there's rules if it's an old ui
overpayment
what what steps need to be followed
there's special rules on
fraud overpayments then there's
different rules on pua overpayments
and then what if you owe an overpayment
from another state
so it requires the division to
follow certain rules and so all of those
are being applied and actually we're
re-looking at
all of those next week just to make sure
we're all on the same page to be able to
communicate with people
so they understand what the rules are
yeah i've been coming
and i'm sure you guys know there's
several posts about
overpayment uh what do i do um if i mean
if someone
is let's say they have been getting
money and then all of a sudden
account frozen and they asked to pay
money back um
is it how do you find out what that's
for is it because of
like a severance or is it because of
fraud i mean what it tell them
yeah it usually does and it could be
like for example
maybe someone didn't really qualify for
the program
so they may be asked to pay it back and
sometimes people can pay it back if
they're still getting their benefits
like from a portion of it
sometimes people can't pay it back right
now right if they're out of work
and so they just make arrangements when
they are able to
right um so that is one of the thing
alisa and i were talking about earlier
we've received a lot of questions about
that
and we'd love to put out some guidance
to people so they can understand the
rules and what their options are
so so that's still in the works yes it
is
i would i would just add sort of at the
at the very basic level when
when you get a notice or a notification
from dieter it will uh generally
give you the the determination that was
made and why
it was made and then what your next
steps and options are um
a lot of these forms were and letters
and notifications were
written years ago um and so
you know they they might be a little bit
difficult to read through but just we
we asked folks to just take the time
read through them
um and make sure that they're sort of
following the next steps because
sometimes
there are timelines that people need to
comply with there are appeal options
usually
there is if you if you did get
money that you should not have gotten or
there's been a determination that you'll
need to pay something back
there's an option for a payment plan so
it's just important for folks to
read those as carefully as they can and
reach out
and sort of at least start the
conversation about what that looks like
uh and that that should give them the
best understanding of their options
um for people who say how the deductions
um
there's i've introduced several people
but one person that comes to mind
um they're asked to pay the money back
but then there's people working
one day a week who are getting a 600
bucks as well how does that
i mean is that something that's gonna be
taken into account moving forward is is
what's fair it's all determined by
federal law
the federal government uh because
like for the pua program they're paying
for it all
so they pretty much have set all the
rules
the same with the unemployment system so
for example um if if they say
oh well you had a week's worth of income
and you received a week's worth of
unemployment you have to pay a hundred
percent of that
back and you know but so
so there's in some of these areas
there's little discretion where there is
discretion i think the goal of the state
is to be fair and to recognize where
hardest hit
and to come up with payment plans and to
do that kind of thing so those are some
of the
policies we're looking at but there's
not a ton of flexibility
and if you if someone is for example
feels that um
they shouldn't have to pay it back do
you suggest maybe filing an appeal what
do you what do you suggest
you know i think what we say to folks is
try
try your best to become informed you
know
um reach out um look at the website
look at the rules because
some of the federal guidelines i don't
think
are the right they i don't like them
but it's the law right so an appeal that
is based on a clear-cut federal law
probably won't be successful
right so i think the best
piece of advice is to get as educated as
you can there's
support groups um there's information on
the web
you know get as educated as you can
about your rights
i don't know what the options are when
it comes to paying back but there are
options and you guys are still going to
move still work
on that next week are there any other
changes um
that are coming soon that people should
know about that you think that
should be noted at all
um well i think we um our
our goal is to uh the focus has always
been
on getting through the backlog getting
caught up
on getting focused claims resolved
we we are doing our best job to
make sure folks know the fastest way to
get
to getting their cases resolved and
getting payment if they're eligible
so um i think i would say there have
been some folks
uh some posts in social media we've seen
that are not
accurate uh in terms of suggesting that
people
stay in pua even if they've been told by
the state that they're
they have to go to back to regular ui
first and exhaust those benefits and
then they can come back to pua
so i would say get informed from uh
reliable sources uh and um
that that will help us you know help
them get their cases resolved
uh we we do have these these staff folks
we are bringing
on so i think we're starting to see some
of the call volumes go down
as we see more cases get resolved that's
fewer people calling through
so we should be able to get to folks
more quickly
as we're processing these these
applications so
i think that people are going to start
just more and more people will start to
see that difference
and be able to get a resolution perfect
last question here on the
lost wages program one second
that's cool um lost wages program uh
is that still an application process
right
our our application is in the uh
the the federal fema asks for some
additional information
in some of our some of the parts of the
application but it's complete
everything's in we expect to hear very
quickly
uh so um as soon as we get the approval
then we will start and plan
probably four to six weeks to make the
system updates
so we can get this money to eligible
nevadans
uh the few notes not everybody who
got the 600 uh bump in unemployment will
be eligible for this
bump unfortunately and again these are
federal rules these are not our roles
um so not everyone's going to get it we
know
that it for sure we'll get three weeks
we will immediately ask for an
additional three weeks
but we know that the program will run
out of money for sure
so we don't know if we'll even get that
second three weeks but we're applying
for it
immediately after we get our approval so
that is what we are hoping for
uh and we hope to have good news very
soon
perfect i'm gonna stop recording it
before it gets too too long